Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and I'm finally able to tell you about something that we have been working on for over a year.
This is CLOAK.
Now CLOAK is our
...clothing...
...brand
This is something that we've been working on for a long time because we wanted to make clothing that we were proud... to tell you about.
We decided that we wanted to make something-- and by the way when I say we,
I mean Jacksepticeye and I, and a team of very smart, very knowledgeable people
about clothing and how to make a company responsibly-- have put together our
heads to try to make clothing that we would want to wear.
Clothes that wasn't just screaming its name at the top of his lungs, clothes that we would be proud to wear.
Clothes that we would be proud of where it came from, of who it represented, and who it was for.
And more specifically it's for you.
This is something that we wanted to make to be
accessible to everybody, something that wasn't restricting someone based on what type of person they were
or what kind of thing they did, is something that people could really identify with.
They could identify with something that didn't want to really be
identified because the clothing is subtle. What we wanted was something that didn't have huge branding about what it was,
clothes that was inherently high-quality, clothes that fit well, clothes that was comfortable,
clothes that just was something that you could wear every single day and be happy wearing it.
We wanted all these things and it's shocking how hard that is to get in clothing today. Every company is so worried about
shouting their brand at the top of their lungs that they kind of forgot about the people that are wearing the clothes in the first place.
We wanted this for you.
And it's not just sweatshirts either. It's a whole bunch of different things.
We wanted to make a different assortment of clothes that you could wear in pretty much any circumstance. We got sweatshirts. We've got t-shirts,
obviously, we've got this which is...
A long-sleeve zip up kind of athletic wear kind of thing.
And as you can see on all these things,
it's not overtly branded. Everything about this company is about hiding in plain sight.
We wanted to have these subtle logos and I love this logo, by the way,
because it's just so simple and nice.
We wanted to have things that
people could really enjoy, things that were comfortable, things that fit well, things that weren't going to fall apart on you on the
second wear. We wanted clothing...
for you.
you can go to cloakbrand.com right now to check out what we have, but it is for
pre-sale. If you order now, you should get it before the end of the year,
but we wanted to be very slow and careful with the launch, so it might sell out very quickly. We're not a hundred percent sure.
We wanted to make sure that everything was smooth and consistent for everybody.
So go to cloakbrand.com, check out the stuff we have, and submit your pre-order right now.
You can also go to CLOAK Brand on Instagram or any of the social media handles and
tomorrow, both Seán(Jack) and I will be doing Instagram live streams throughout the day,
answering your questions about this, talking about this some more, and basically just telling you guys what we have in store in the future.
We have mostly upper body wear (right now), but we will have leggings, sweat pants, shorts,
we're gonna be expanding it throughout this next year and
next year and next year and next year as we make this thing grow bigger and better than we could ever hope for.
So please go to cloakbrand.com. Check it out. Actually... be gentle with the website.
It is something that we are just starting. You guys have a habit of breaking
everything that we tell you to go to, but please be careful.
I now realize that both Seán and I are telling you to go to the same website at the same time.
Just please be gentle with the website. The link is in the description. If it's down, please don't spam it.
We're trying our best here *giggles* Just be gentle with our baby. We just got it. It's- it's- it's fresh. It's fragile.
Please be careful with it.
And remember, you can submit a pre-order right now at cloakbrand.com and you will get it before the end of the year,
hopefully, but does take time to make clothing of this quality, and we want to make sure that everything is done right
so it's a good experience for everybody buying from start to finish.
So it's a pre-sale. Be careful with the website... baby.
Please be careful and gentle with the baby.
So thank you, everybody, so much for watching. I am super duper excited about this. I've been waiting so long,
I've been bursting at the seams, and I just can't wait for you to see this stuff in person.
It is the best clothing that I could ever hope for. This is something that I'm gonna wear almost every single day.
So thank you everybody so much for watching. And as always, I will see you in the next video.
Bye Bye!